There's a trend in many industries
to face a lot of new challenges,
every industry now is either undergoing or
is seeing the threat or
the promise of disruption.
[MUSIC]
This program is all about
delivering value for your company.
Getting the mechanisms to actually
drive innovation in your organization.
>> The big challenge I think, is figuring
out how to innovate at large corporations.
It's exactly what this
program was geared around.
So it felt like it was a perfect fit.
>> The program actually brings
together three strengths of
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
The first one is really our expertise
in creating new businesses.
The second one is our expertise in
innovation in large organization,
in a corporate setting.
And the third one is all about
the idea of organizational change.
>> I found the two companies and
now I'm at a big corporate company.
The program is ideally suited
because it links the two, right?
My entrepreneurial spirit with the
sometimes obstacles in big corporations.
>> I was looking for something that
would really lead me towards innovation,
I really found that the structure of this
program was going to be ideal for me.
>> My role is to be
the corporate entrepreneur.
And I often find myself in
a place where nobody gets or
understands what I'm thinking or
trying to do.
And so I wanted to find a place where I
belonged, and that I could associate with
other people who were thinking
in similar patterns to me.
>> The project component makes it
an experiential learning in a much more
effective practical experience.
These are real projects,
our participants bring in the project.
Some of the projects
become the way to learn.
By going through a real project and
working on it and developing it.
We see the content from the classroom
actually being applied in a real
life setting,
where a lot of the learning occurs.
>> The experiential aspect
was extremely important, and
that's what sets this program
apart from other programs.
You get to live what you learn,
and see if it actually works,
and see if you can execute on it.
>> The cohort is fabulous,
we have people from all around the world.
We're all this corporate entrepreneur who
feel that the rest of the organisation
doesn't always get us.
And some people get us but not everybody,
and that we're in this thing together.
>> You're surrounded by people
who have very similar issues.
You learn a lot from
the experience of others, but
it also becomes sort of a support
group for the corporate entrepreneur,
which creates long lasting networks
that are useful in the future.
>> The world is turning faster.
Even Google now has to take care to
keep the speed and keep the innovation.
You need a constant rethinking of
your ideas of new business models,
a constant innovation.
>> The program helps you take an idea and
develop it, evaluate it,
communicate it, and
finally have the tools to execute on it.
[MUSIC]